my guy what's going on you a Muslim yeah
bro I ain't gonna lie I'm I'm a newer
Muslim though so I'm not here to try to
like you know refute or argue or none of
that extra stuff I'll be see I be seeing
you on the internet I ain't gonna lie I
be seeing how you get down you know what
I'm saying okay I'm more or less I want
to see I want to see what you be talking
about bro so a couple basic simple
questions for real is um I guess I would
say how do you understand the um what's
the word what's the word the anous
author idea when it comes down to like
Hebrews or you know Matthew may not have
write wrote Matthew and John out a wrote
John and blah blah blah like how do you
how do you
uh yeah yeah yeah for sure okay so one
with Matthew Mark L and John it's not
Anon it's it's not Anonymous like we
don't know who wrote it right so when
you talk about anonymity you have
different concepts of it you have um
Anonymous meaning the author didn't put
their name in their work doesn't mean we
don't know who the author is just that
they didn't you know uh you know sign it
with their name right so you have
different works like that in history
where certain historians they don't put
their names in the work but we know who
wrote it we know who it's attributed to
and stuff like that we have examples
like that okay okay I don't I don't I
don't I don't mean to pause but I gotta
hold on one
second all right all right I don't know
if I paused or not um my bad were you
were you going to continue yeah so
that's with Matthew Mark L John we know
who wrote it their names are on the
manuscripts that we have and also like
the church fathers which are Disciples
of the disciples right they walked with
them knew them um they also claim
attribute their writings to to these
people it's unanimous in early church
history it's never a disagreement on who
wrote the gospels okay now when it comes
to like for example the book of Hebrews
there's a little bit more that's a
little bit more am ambiguous there's no
real definitive answer on that a lot of
people um lean towards Paul um some
people lean towards it's Luke who wrote
it at the dictation of Paul so that's
you know you have different theories
like that most people lean towards Paul
but what we see in the book of Hebrews
is that it's apostolic meaning it comes
from an apostle right they claim to be
an apostle and to witness the
resurrected Christ and stuff like that
so we know and the early church test
that okay yeah this is Apostolic it's
written by an apostle so it's good even
though we don't know specifically like
with a definitive 100% which apostle
wrote it we know with 100% that it is
written by an apostle so that's why it's
still okay okay so and with that too if
we don't know I guess the specific
identity behind say Hebrews right
because again I mean things get a little
controversial I guess in other
conversations with other people whatever
but say
how do we how do we know the the
reliability behind the author who wrote
these things like if they were
trustworthy if they were really you know
during the time that they claim to be or
you know especially with with a lack of
physical uh you know obviously you know
the whole thing behind the manuscripts
and the and the p52 and stuff like that
like how do we go about like you say
reconciling with those things with the
with the with the with the true lack of
you know something tangible that we can
you know we do we do we do have it see
we don't we don't need the we don't need
a first century document to know what
the apostles wrote and who they are we
have the copies of their manuscripts and
we have oral tradition and an Apostolic
succession meaning there are people who
came after the apostles right the church
as Bishops Bishops are passed down right
they're yeah you know people take these
positions now you know we have that line
of succession of the Apostles that
continued the Traditions so if you look
into the early church history early
church fathers which is something I'm
studying Myself by the way and it's
fascinating what I'm what I'm looking at
the history behind it all you see this
there wasn't one disagreement dude there
wasn't one disagreement over Matthew
Mark Luke and John never all of them
agreed it's
unanimous every time you you talk about
the authorship of the gospels it's
always Matthew Mark luk and John never a
difference okay so and and and I and
again I'm a little bit newer to all this
so I'm still in the process of learning
I don't really I don't really like to
learn to try to argue um so when it
comes down to and this is something that
I heard I'll admit I'll admit stuff that
I heard and not just something that I've
been able to do my research on because I
haven't but when it comes down to the
idea of you know that there were
councils like the Council of nah and the
Council of Constantinople who were able
to come up with in 325 and 381 who were
able to discuss the idea of the Trinity
and the relationship between Jesus peace
be upon him and God
um
where what what what was the idea of
like who how did those four names get
picked wasn't there was there more was
there more names and more people who
wrote more gospels and those got picked
out of all of the rest of them like and
if so for what reason yeah so no there
weren't there weren't other gospels that
that were considered like again not even
considered not considered there was when
I when I tell you hear me what I'm
saying this I'm hearing I'm hearing you
the early church was
unanimous meaning everyone agreed there
was no disagreement on who authored the
gospel accounts there's no disagreement
there was not no not a doubt amongst any
of them and what year what year are we
talking when we say the early church
fathers that that were to that made this
agreement that came that came we're talk
we're talking late late and early so
late first century early 2 century and
beyond so mostly second century right
some of them you know lived in the late
first century because some of them knew
the apostles and walked with them
learned under them like and what are
these names if you don't mind me asking
ignacius
uhhuh uh
papus p a p i p i a
papus
polycarp polycarp that's uh that's
something to do with the p52 no no no no
no that's
papy polycarp is a
polycarp
papy
yeah polycarp was a was was under John
he he walked under John the Apostle who
wrote the Gospel um so you got Ignatius
papius irus
um polycarp Clement of Rome whose some
say is actually mentioned in one of
Paul's letters I believe or is it acts I
think it's in in the letters of Paul but
Clement is me mentioned in the scripture
and another one that's another big and I
don't mean to cut you off my bad bro I'm
just kind of like letting them fly you
feel me yeah
Paul um what's what's up with him like
he was never around he was never there
for real he was there for real for real
he had a he had a he had a vision Right
One Vision he didn't have a vision
something
happened which was what which that Jesus
appeared to him blinded him knocked him
off his high horse and stopped him from
persecuting the church so it wasn't a
vision no bro have you have you read it
have you read Paul no you I be honest
it's it's it's short you mind us going
through it real quick I mean let's do it
bro let's do
it well and then and then and then as
you're pulling it up um the idea of the
devil being able to reveal himself to
somebody whether in a dream or out of a
dream in a vision out of a vision in the
form of a life
how does that how does that not you know
raise a question mark at all in in your
I'll show you how not okay but then I
want to I want to ask you this before I
show you this and answer
this do you do you approach the Quran
with the same skepticism honestly I do
not well I do when it comes down to
skepticism of course I have to I have to
question things I have to want to learn
these things bro I'm not I didn't grow
up around either religion especially not
the politics of either one so coming
down with this I got to be even minded I
got to be fair minded now the main
comparison that I've heard just on some
on a quick tip between Paul and Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him receiving
Revelation or having visions dreams
whatever you want to call them the idea
of that being Paul had now correct me if
I'm wrong I know you will Paul had this
Encounter With Jesus peace be upon him
in the the light form however you want
to call it and Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him had the angel Gabriel alisam
arrive to him year after year after year
after year with other people as well
other companions as well seeing him come
in the form of a of a man and all white
now that versus a blinding vision of
some light that speaks to you doesn't
really hit the same for me you feel me
and again this is not no no bias kind of
Minds let's investigate because what we
what you have is nobody witnessed
Muhammad's
um Revelation or Gabriel coming to Mom
nobody witnessed that there's a claim of
oh the person that you saw walking out
this tent oh that was Gabriel as a claim
by so Thea by people who are who are not
prophets and not messengers of God I'm
gonna show you the difference let me
show you the difference okay okay okay
okay so let's read Paul let's read about
Paul in the book of
Acts and let's see what what what's
what's going on here man and I'mma show
you how it doesn't even compare to
Muhammad
so but Saul still breathing threats and
murder against the Disciples of the Lord
this Acts chapter nine by the way Acts
chapter
nine went to the high priest and asked
him for letters to the synagogues at
Damascus so that he found any belonging
to the way that was what they were
called the Christians at the time men or
women he might bring them bound to
Jerusalem
now as he was sent on his
way he approached Damascus and suddenly
a light from Heaven Shone around him and
falling to the ground he heard a voice
saying to him Saul Saul why are you
persecuting
me and he said who are you Lord and he
said I am Jesus whom you are persecuting
but rise and enter the city and you will
be told what you are to
do the men who were traveling with him
stood speechless hearing a voice but
seeing no
one so they didn't even see the light
okay got you got
you um oh I'm sorry they didn't see the
person they didn't see the person sorry
and who are with they did see the light
though yeah I think they saw the light
but they didn't see the they didn't see
Jesus anybody right right right and who
were these these guys that were with him
just other people that were there were
his dogs that he was rocking with that
about to go persecute the Christians
okay no Identity or anything like that
not
necessarily Saul Rose from the ground
and although his eyes were opened he saw
nothing so they led him by the hand and
brought him into Damascus and for three
days he he was without sight and neither
ate nor
drank now we see what happen we see that
Paul has an experience Jesus comes to
him while he's on his way to commit evil
acts Jesus stops him from doing the evil
acts that sound like Satan to you not
necessarily but I do I do I do like to
add that as well when a lot of
Christians say that um Islam is some
sort of inspiration from the devil Islam
teaches a lot of everything that goes
against the devil so I mean that aside
from accepting Jesus as our Lord and
savior I guess you can see it teaches it
teaches a lot of things that that that
go right along with the devil I'll show
you this stuff I I'll I'll show you if
you and if you you can't kind of came to
the stream a little late but for you
I'll show you everything I I stream
Monday Wednesdays and Fridays bro so if
you want to ever catch me Monday
Wednesday Friday same time that's when I
stream okay sure for sure all right but
look so this is what happen so Paul this
happens to him on his way to commit evil
is stopped from doing evil and he has
others that are there that witnessed the
experience to some degree not fully
right but they witnessed The Experience
right they heard the voice and they saw
the light right they heard the voice
they saw the
light okay now now there was a disciple
at Damascus named
ananas the Lord said to him in a vision
ananas and he said Here I Am Lord and
the Lord said to him r
and go to the street called straight and
at the house of Judas look for a man of
Tarsus named Saul for behold he is
praying and he has seen in a vision a
man named ananas come in and lay his
hands on him so that he might regain his
sight but ananas answered Lord H I have
heard from many about this man how much
evil he has done to your Saints at
Jerusalem
and here he has Authority from the chief
priest to bind all who call on your name
but the Lord said to him go for he is a
chosen instrument of mine to carry my
name before the Gentiles and Kings and
the children of Israel for I will show
him how much he must suffer for the sake
of my name and what is this one of
Paul's letters no this is this is Luke
wrote the book of Acts not
Paul okay so here we have not only did
Paul have witnesses to his his initial
encounter right the soldiers that were
there but also a a disciple of the Lord
is another witness a disciple of the
Lord received a revelation yep ananas he
received a revelation that confirms the
Revelation that Paul received so
disciples Reed direct Revelations from
God yep the same way that prophets
receive direct Revelations from God yeah
in a way yeah absolutely go do they do
they do they do
they God gives Revelation to whoever he
wants direct Revelation yeah direct
Revelation to whoever he wants you know
I mean even even you believe that you
know Revelation can be given to even
nonprofits like Revelation came to Mary
she's not a prophet right but the Angels
Came to her and told her she's going to
have a son and stuff all the kind of
stuff you know you have examples where
nonprofits receive direct Revelations
right are there more are there more than
Mary I mean at this point you probably
know a little bit yeah um Mo Moses's uh
Moses's mother she received wahi to put
him in the basket that's what the Quran
says that she received inspiration from
Allah to put Moses in the basket to
preserve him to save him from Pharaoh
that's what the Quran says um you
have I don't I don't I don't remember
the verse off the top of my head bro but
but but the I I'll give you another
verse actually the the verse in the
Quran says that if you go to chapter 5
verse uh
111 chapter 5 verse 111 of the
Quran it talks about how the disciples
themselves received inspiration from
Allah to believe inspiration or like
direct Revelation it's it's re
inspiration is revelation it's wah the
word is wahi which means Revelation it
can be translated as Revelation or
inspiration but it's God you know
revealing or giving knowledge or
inspiration of you know or awareness or
Enlightenment okay so with this with
this um book of you said book of Acts
right is what we're reading right now y
y the book of Acts with this book of
Acts given the idea and again these are
just questions bro regular questions I
want to I want to get into the the
Christian mind a little bit I don't talk
to any knowledgeable Christians I'll be
honest like I said I'm newer to Islam
personally so that's what I'm here for
for sure for sure so with with
this the idea that or the fact that the
earliest manuscripts of the full
complete Bible aren't until say I think
the fourth Century early to mid fourth
century No that's not true you're
talking about a compilation of it not
the actual manuscripts so what would the
what would what would when was the full
complete Bible done compiled I mean I I
don't know hon I don't have an answer
for that um but we have manuscripts that
are earlier than the fourth century and
third so like after p52 which is what
about 125
150 p52 p52 is is second century that's
a copy and we have other stuff as well
like you can look this I don't have this
the dates off the top of my head but you
can look the stuff up where what's the
names of of of maybe the next one after
p52 I don't know I don't know this is
something this something you got to look
up look are you familiar with like the
Codex sinus and the Cod
codex anticus is um a full completed
codex of the Bible right we have
manuscripts before that that's my point
and you don't know any can you look can
you look a couple up for me real quick
if you don't mind just hold on a second
B hold on we got to finish the Paul
thing first bro hey that's but that's my
thing though right yeah one one step at
a time one step at a time let's do so
with Paul you have the witnesses that
were there that
experience you have um you have another
disciple of the Lord who received
Revelation that confirmed Paul's
Revelation that he received do you have
that for Muhammad do you have for
Muhammad one Witnesses at his cave or
another disciple or messenger of God
that received a revelation that um that
you know corresponded with the
Revelation that Muhammad received
I don't know so I can't really answer
that the answer to that is no answer to
that I don't know so I had to do my
homework personally um that ain't really
something that I can I can give a direct
answer on I could I I mean I believe
that you you know what you're talking
about but at the same time you feel me I
gotta yeah this is this is the big
difference between Paul and and Muhammad
Paul had witnesses to his Revelation
Muhammad doesn't he doesn't have a
single one it's just him he's a lone
wolf matter of fact it wasn't even him
who recognized that he was a prophet he
had to be told by somebody else who's
not a a prophet not a messenger not a
disciple somebody named wara told him
that he was a prophet and where is this
where is this information from so you'll
you'll find this in the Hadith in
sahkari this is the most authentic book
next to the Quran and Islam right
Islamic right right for sure so you'll
find this in in Sai bukari in the early
ones you know in the Book of Revelation
it'll give you Muhammad's story and show
you where waraka is the one who told him
oh yeah don't worry about it you're a
prophet but when Muhammad came out of
his experience notice the difference
Paul has his experience and Paul
immediately understands that he's
speaking with the Lord and He submits to
the Lord right now he gets blinded
because of you know what he's doing and
then ananas goes and heals him of his
blindness with Muhammad in his
experience the spirit comes upon Him
presses on him until he can't take it
anymore until he can't bear it anymore
he's being oppressed by the spirit to
read when he can't read and he comes out
trembling filled with Terror and fear
and also thinking that he was
demon-possessed I'll probably be scared
too bro I ain't gonna lie I can't I
can't even really look at that that
because I've I've heard the way y'all
describe it I've seen a lot of your
videos bro I've heard the way that y'all
describe these these type of things like
oh he was choking them and this this and
that people people like to make it sound
weird I get where the perception can
come from but me personally I'll
probably be scared too bro and I
wouldn't really know it's real until I
actually felt something so the the
problem with this bam is when you
compare the experiences with the
prophets and the disciples with when God
comes to them or when an angel comes to
them right you'll never ever see a
prophet or an apostle get confused
thinking that they are possessed by a
demon being oppressed coming out with
trembling in fear in the sense that you
know they're scared for their life type
of stuff right
um they they'll there there's no
confusion in instead they'll say wow I
just saw god wow God just visited me and
I'm still alive or and initially when an
angel comes they'll be afraid because
you know you'll be startled somebody
just appears out of nowhere of course
yeah for sure for sure but immediately
the the angel said says peace I come in
peace be still right um and
immediately he brings peace to the
situation there's no more fear or
tribling here so we see a a stark
difference with the experiences with
angels and the and God prophets and
disciples versus Muhammad sure but
however we see with Muhammad's
experience when we read how demons come
on people we see Stark similarities
foaming at the mouth fear and trembling
fainting breaking out in sweats we see
that with demon possession but then
what's but then where's the difference
when do those people that end up getting
possessed by demons end up actually
prospering and and able to teach these
lessons that turn into positives
victories and prophecies about the
future or do they end at the demon
possession Muhammad has no Prophecies of
The Future Has I got okay so so one for
you that I would I would like to hear
what you have to say are we did we
establish what we were saying about Paul
and stuff though did you did you
understand the the the difference of
course of course of course I did so this
is this is why Paul has more weight
infinitely more weight than Muhammad
Muhammad has no witnesses to this stuff
I understand that and then what again
real real quick what couple verses was
that in Acts whatap this is Acts chapter
nine acts nine you want to read from
verse
one to
19 got you so real quick I want to hear
what you got to think about this or got
to say about this so um there's a
prophecy and it was definitely in one of
the hadiths obviously I mean I I I I
gotta go find it somehow again I'm I'm
I'm newer to surfing a lot of phrase it
I might know what you're talking about
for sure so the prophecy is about the
bedwin bedwin Arabs um who will naked
Barefoot better ons who will compete and
build in tall buildings who will compete
and Building the tallest buildings um
using one of the resources that the
Earth will puke that turns into or that
will be abundant for all of those Arabs
and I mean you you obviously get what
I'm talking about uh Dubai and uh I
think it's Saudi Arabia or somebody
that's actually building up the one of
the newest tallest buildings where did
where did where did why would that come
into play I guess within the last 50200
years the people that are building this
these uh buildings are they naked and
Barefoot better ones they were yeah no
they Dubai was Dubai was just a desert
not
it says that naked Barefoot bins will
compete in building TP buildings but
they're not naked Barefoot bins these
are businessmen who are building tall
buildings and by the way it's not even
it's not even the bins who are doing or
their or these Arabs do the tallest
building in Dubai was built by an
American business so what was Dubai not
like just 5 to 100 years ago if you're
if you're talking about 52 100 years ago
I I would I would show you that if
you're talking about the tallest
buildings being built Dubai is not the
one doing it it's an American Business
that built their tallest buildings so I
mean I guess you would just say that's
like a
coincidence the prophecy say bam bam the
prophecy says that the naked Barefoot
better ons would compete I get what
you're saying you're saying that they're
not naked they're not
Barefoot not the ones building it the
the Americans are so would you say that
it would just be a coincidence
acquin in what that the those those not
the people obviously not the not the B
and Arabs like your point is but the the
in in Saudi Arabia and Dubai where there
were naked bed and Arabs which they may
not be building the buildings right now
which is like I said your point so it's
a false prophecy if they're not the ones
building the buildings so it's a false
prophecy yes okay got you so then what
about like say can I can I show you
another false prophecy sure okay so you
have Muhammad he predicts like end times
and stuff like that signs and all that
kind of
stuff this one here he actually says
that the last hour will come in the
lifetime of one of the one of the kids
that was
there
[Music]
um my bad bro I'm burping it's okay man
we're all human here professional you
know right right right right right
dang it I used to have this Hadith the
number memorized by heart
however I am y your comment section be
sold like welcome to the internet y
ruthless what's up with y'all it's the
internet C tell this guy take his hoodie
off and he'll be recognized do I look
like I'm
unrecognized guys leave him alone man
leave him alone let let him let him let
him let him speak man I I don't we don't
want no distractions though we don't we
don't need any distractions it's the
soda it's definitely the soda gon
lie they believe anything and everything
I mean yo if I'm humbl enough to come
and ask some questions you feel what I'm
saying I ain't gonna sit here and refute
[Music]
things he's cool appreciate you truth
fire n this funny bro I ain't gonna lie
I never been on one of these live
platforms before it's it's cool man
appreciate you for letting me on bro of
course it's cool man y'all y'all cool
all y'all cool I ain't even tripping you
mean let it Let It Fly Let it Fly I know
most of y'all probably young most of
y'all probably around my age and younger
for real for
real yeah we young around here man we we
we we young around here you a grown man
ain't you like 25
26 maybe 27
28 I a't gon expose you my dying
laughing in the other room
bro I'm
[Laughter]
damn I'm 30 man yeah everybody here
probably my age bro I'm 19 years old bro
you you a grown man at 19 what I mean
yeah but that's why I said my age and
younger bro a lot of these people
probably about 16 17 on Tik Tok watching
the debates and you mean getting all in
their emotions stuff man I'm here to
learn man I'm here
this what Hadith is this by the way and
do you know the grading at all sah
Muslim
2953 so it's right there with uh bukari
just right right under him
so it says anas reported that a person
asked Allah's Messenger as to when the
last hour would come he had in his
presence a young boy of the ansar who
was called Muhammad Allah's messenger
said said if this young boy lives he may
not grow very old till he would see the
last hour coming to
you that boy
dead
chill chill on Chill on the young man
hey that man gone man I mean I get I get
where you getting at um I get where you
getting at I don't I mean it don't
really sound too direct uh he may not
grow very old to the last to to he would
see the last hour coming to you I mean
meaning it be in his lifetime meaning
the last hour is going to come if this
and if and he if he's growing old he's
going to see it so in his lifetime he
would see
it for sure that's not bad I mean I'm
I'm G keep that one in sah Muslim
now you know this is
uh this is uh pretty clear and
straightforward they asked about the
last hour uhuh they ask him about
Judgment Day and he tells them when it's
going to come it doesn't for sure for
sure you get you could you mean for sure
I see exactly where you going with it I
can't even I can't doubt nothing I can't
accept nothing I got to do my homework
you would be dumb to be able to just sit
and accept and doubt things without you
I mean doing your
little what about I have a question for
you you said you've seen my videos
you've been watching a lot of stuff I
was gonna ask you a question about one
of your videos too how long you been a
Muslim I've been a Muslim
since um I took my shahada last
summertime so it ain't really been that
long bro and then I really was hasn't
even been a year it really hasn't and I
and I come from a a um not so righteous
lifestyle so it's been about I say four
to five I say about four months since I
was actually able to knock all that
stuff out the table for God like I said
bro because at the end of the day the
politics are was coming now the things
about the research and stuff like that
is coming now but when it came down to
fixing my lifestyle bro it was something
I never thought I was going to be able
to do for real like I had a lot of
visions of me growing older still having
these habits and stuff like that
sticking with me but you know I I say by
the grace of God I was able to be lifted
up out of those weird that weird energy
the weird surroundings I was in and
loneliness used to hurt bro but ever
since I've been able to continue to
worship God on my longone time and get
away from those bad habits on my long
time bro it feels a lot a lot better lot
so this so so with you seeing my videos
have you you've seen me talk about
Muhammad you seen me talk about his
character I want to ask you about
something specific that everybody always
knows and talks about ask me bro Ahad
all right so you know about his
relationship with Aisha right I do and
you're okay with
that nowadays I wouldn't say it's
something that we would normalize as a
society no is it okay though nowadays I
wouldn't say so no okay so you're saying
don't see anybody really doing that not
in America anyway I mean country if
everybody was if everybody was doing it
would would it would it be would it make
it okay for me no period according to
everybody else who does it maybe but me
personally I don't think my opinion
you're you're a theist you believe in
God so this means that morality isn't
subjective it doesn't change morality
there are objective morals you know what
I'm saying sure so there are things that
are right and wrong wrong regardless of
the time you're in regardless of the
culture regardless of the era or
generation you're from right is right
and wrong is wrong right would you would
would you agree with that I agree with
that yes so for example here's example I
like to use the enslavement of Africans
against their will forcing them into
labor you know graping their women and
taking their children from them and
raising them as
slaves no matter what generation you're
in or time you're in that's always wrong
would you agree I agree yeah even though
that was popular to do at the time and
multiple Nations and cultures were doing
it and said it was
okay still it's not okay right objectiv
I I don't think it's okay objectively no
good so what about graping a woman is
there ever a time where graping a woman
is okay I don't think so right no matter
what time no matter the popularity the
culture doesn't matter that's is always
wrong I would like to give my
understanding on the relationship
between the prophet peace be upon him
and Aisha as well I will I'll let you do
that just so I want to ask this last one
no problem is it ever okay for an adult
man to have relations with a little
girl um no not not in I wouldn't compare
that regular question to the context
that we're referring to but uh if that
girl is not at all mentally or
physically matured or ready for any kind
of relationships with anybody I don't
think so no so you think a 9-year-old
girl can be sexually mature and
physically and mentally mature to be
married to a 50-year-old man and have
sexual relations with him I mean all
women are different some mature quicker
some don't I can't really compare to all
so you believe that a nine-year-old girl
can be a woman I believe that she was
physically matured enough yeah I think
she had yeah so you believe a
nine-year-old can be a woman a grown
woman a grown woman
I think that's a different terminology
so you believe a nine-year-old can be a
woman I would say that a nine-year-old
can can go through certain levels of
puberty That Make Her physically ready
yeah so and my understanding behind that
is one I mean that can still happen to
this day when it comes down to women but
two yeah why do we call those people
pedophiles I I mean what's the
definition of a pedophile one who loves
a child who has attractions with a child
for
children I mean
I don't I don't really see pedophilia as
okay honestly but that's what that's
what you're advocating for so that
that's why I said I wanted to get my
understanding you know if I could all
right bet so one
um God God wouldn't well God allows God
allows evil to take place in the world
so I can't even say that God wouldn't
allow certain things that are bad but
when it comes down to my beliefs anyway
because that's what we're talking about
now my beliefs you got your beliefs I
got mine blah blah blah I'm advocating
for what God allows so in this case God
allowed the prophet to one her parents
allowed this as well Abu Bakr which is
one of the prophet's closest peace be
upon him his closest companions Abu Bakr
objected he objected to
what he gave a passive aggressive
objection when muham Muhammad came to
him and said I want your daughter in
marriage ababaka was like but we're
brothers and Muhammad was like we're
only Brothers in the
faith and then and then he gave him gave
her gave her up so what was he forced by
gunpoint if you're the prophet if you're
the prophet basically because you can't
disagree with any of Muhammad's
decisions that's chapter um chapter four
in the Quran I don't know but I'm I'm I
still wanted to get my understanding on
it anyway so one Abu Baka which is her
father allowed that to happen um he
allowed her to I mean that has to happen
that's a that's a law and we at least
our side as Muslims we know uh the
prophet peace be upon him as a righteous
man who who follows laws who follows you
know guidances and whatnot and wasn't
one to be um loud aggressive going
against any kind of rulings and stuff
like you're basically saying it's okay
because her parents gave her away and
then God I mean I was still trying to
explain my understanding on it but you
mean can I can I get through it real
quick or you're not though get to it
then all
right so um yes one that's my one point
is that her parents were perfectly fine
with it okay good so let's let's discuss
that so if your parent is perfectly fine
with giving away a nine-year-old is that
okay according to her parents
yeah I didn't say according to the
parents I'm asking is it okay
objectively is it okay objectively if a
parent gives their nine-year-old away to
a grown man is that okay is that right I
mean I'm I'm still trying to trying to
you I'm saying get the basis of the
point because that's that's one part of
it I know I'm dealing with point one
where let's go point at a time and let's
see I mean I can't speak for all parents
and all people this is a specific we're
speaking objectively we're not speaking
subject remember we just established
that there are things that are wrong
regardless of who you are regardless of
your culture generation or time we
already are things like there are things
like that okay so I'm asking if a if
parents if a father decided to give his
9-year-old little girl up for marriage
to a 54 year old
man is that okay is that morally okay
that is physically ready for marriage
and past a as a level of puberty
physically physically ready a
nine-year-old physically ready I mean
can you can you show me where
scientifically there's no nine-year-old
ever that's been through puberty had her
period and stuff like that uh go having
your starting your period is not you
being physically ready it's your body
maturing and getting ready just because
you your period starts doesn't mean
you're a woman now you're you're growing
I mean I feel you but like I said there
was circumstances behind it which
obviously God and in our beliefs anyway
because I know you believe what you
believe bro you know what I'm saying you
you you do this you spend your time
going against Islam so I mean I get what
you going to say but um God is not going
to allow that to happen if it there was
anything morally wrong about that that's
not true at all you already said that
God allows morally bad things to happen
that's why I'm saying in our beliefs I
believe that Islam is true and that the
prophet peace be upon Him is a true
prophet of God and God even if even if
this was bad even even if this was bad
it being allowed doesn't mean that God
doesn't exist or whatever I didn't I
didn't I didn't okay so God allows God
allows bad things to happen and take
place still we have our free will on
this planet on this Earth for sure so
Muhammad committing this horrible act
doesn't mean that oh since he did it
that means God let him do it or God um
not not just let but God willed for him
to do it God wanted him to do it that
God thinks it's okay because God We
believe We believe that those
circumstances were okay I I know you do
I know you do but him doing it doesn't
mean that God thought it was okay for
this to
happen according according to your
opinion for sure but I was still trying
to get my understanding across if that's
fine with you because the you you
established that the first point with
the parents and whatnot you don't think
that's okay I said there's more
circumstances to it than just a general
statement if that's not accepted cool
like I was so wait so did we did we
establish that you're saying if parents
find it okay to give up their
nine-year-old to a 54 year old that
objectively that's morally good that's
morally okay with circum certain
circumstance behind it yeah all right
like these like these specific
circumstances now I want to ask you this
too then can I can I continue where I
was going or no almost almost just a
second before before coming to Islam bam
did you did you think did you have this
this line of thought I never thought
about it you never thought about it nope
so so in your mind it never like it
never came across that you know a
nine-year-old is a child who who
shouldn't be with a having sex with a
man I never thought about niney olds
having sex at all
bro of of course because that's like out
of the it's out of the out of the
picture right it's it's a no no right so
it wasn't until this L came in your life
that you started to now think about this
and say oh well you know what M maybe so
yeah a nine-year-old yeah can have sex
with a grown man well the way you're
wording it and again I've watched some
of your videos bro so I know what I know
what you I know how you like to you mean
but again we're talking specific
circumstances I don't think about
regular niney old girls and regular old
men this regular niney old girl was
playing with dolls you you think you
think she was mature enough and grown
enough to sleep with a with a 54 year
old man playing with dolls I don't think
that has anything to do with her
physical maturity well it does if I can
get back to my let me let me show you
that it has everything to do with it let
me show you but can I get back to my
understanding all right so if she's
physically if she's physically ready
physically mature to a certain level um
to where there's no one there's no harm
on her obviously I'm not trying to get
explicit because this is this YouTube no
no this is Islam be explicit you have to
be this is Islam this is YouTube though
it's YouTube which allows us the freedom
to speak freely about the disgusting
measures in
Islam all right bro all right all right
before I go to my understanding actually
I don't want to do that because you g
you gonna take me somewhere else so
boom um her father obviously it needs to
be that's a that's a necessity in Islam
I want you to read this bro can you read
this for
me only if you promise that I can get to
my understanding after this but you make
a lot of promises that you don't stick
to my gu like what which one uh I seen
your debates with shikan Y moment what's
a promise that I didn't keep y'all
getting the moment he he even does the
same thing so I ain't advocating for him
no no B what's a promise that I did not
keep I mean I can't say your word
specifically but there's certain moments
where don't do that you say there's
certain moments where you'll say um I'll
let you speak and I won't interrupt and
you interrupt he'll do the same thing
let him speak it okay let him speak it
get like but we all we all watch you we
all know how I go but we all watch me
and we all know how patient I am with
the Muslims but I'm not a pushover
either I'll read it for you I'll read it
for you um I used to play with dogs in
the presence of the Prophet sallallahu
alai wasam and my girl friends used to
play with me when Allah's Apostle used
to enter my ding place they used to hide
they used to hide themselves but the
prophet will call them to join and play
with her the playing with the dolls and
similar images is forbidden but it was
allow fora at the time she was a little
girl not yet reached the age of puberty
so is this when they were already
consumated their marriage or no
yes how do you know let me show you I'm
glad you asked thank you thank you
and then what Hadith was that as
well s
bukari
okay excuse me again guys fellas
chat all right so nasty
bro so here's the
Hadi go ahead and read
this out loud and proud with your chess
my bad I was going to ask a question
real quick does that mean that this same
exact passage is from the same exact
moment that she was with her friends in
that in that in that time this is about
the moment when it was consummated and
what was going on she used to have her
dolls with her when she was consummated
with but does that mean that that exact
moment happened after it was already
consummated it means that she was
allowed to play with dolls even after
her marriage with Muhammad because she
was still a little girl so she only she
only played with dolls after they they
they were consumated like the only still
she played with dolls before and
continued after she used to live with
him and her girlfriends used to come
over and play with her playing with
dolls so the first the first Hadith that
you showed me does that show anywhere in
that specific Hadith that in that moment
where she was with her friends before
she reached the age of puberty that they
had already consummated the marriage or
she yes yes it's because she's living
with him she's in his house now that
that Hadith shows that she's at
Muhammad's house now and she was living
with him yeah
where does it say that she was living
with him ju just read this Hadith bro oh
I see it she they were married when she
was six consummated when she was nine
she used to play with dogs so when she
consum when the marriage was consummated
she still played with dogs right yes
okay so she was not mature and still a
little girl when Muhammad consummated
the marriage with her right so but in
that other Hadith is what I'm saying
though in that other Hadith where it
says before she reached the age of
puberty does that specifically say she
was nine brother look at this was she
nine when she used to play with dolls
she could have been five when she used
to play with dolls according to this
according to this Hadith was she nine
when she used to play with dolls when I
was nine and I used to play with dolls
you can assume so yeah okay good that's
what it plainly says now watch what this
says we'll read the relevant part of
what I just showed you the playing with
dolls and similar images is
forbidden but it was allowed for Aisha
at that
time at she was a little girl not yet
reached the age of puberty what so the
only reason why she able to play with
dolls is because she was a little girl
when it says Allah's Apostle right there
and this may be my ignorance is it still
speaking of prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him as Allah's Apostle yeah okay so
it says that when he used to enter her
dwelling place no that's in parenthesis
that's not there but that would be her
room as well her bedroom okay
okay so yeah again I'm not really seeing
that it's 100% fact that she was because
that's what I mean she had already
passed a certain age that they could
consummate the marriage or there would
or they would have probably consummated
it when she was six brother oh
man you feel me that would have that may
have been bad that may have been bad but
I don't see the reason that may have
been bad no I think that if he did it at
six you'd still be making an excuse for
it I'm not I'm not saying it like that
I'm saying like
if she you're you quick bro I ain't
gonna lie you
quick I gotta be doing this man I gotta
no first first I get you what reason
would they have to wait until she and I
do still got to get my understanding
across because you promis me you promis
me but what reason would they have to
wait until she was nine if if um because
maybe at first she couldn't handle it
because maybe at first she couldn't
handle it so what means at nine years
old she can handle it uh Avery he was
able it was able to he was able to
penetrator
okay so
again bro this is the religion you
joined no that's cool that's cool
because I don't I don't I don't see it
how how I guess you Christians would see
it no no no it's not about how
Christians would see anybody anybody not
anybody that's not Muslim right anybody
that's not Muslim can clearly see you
know so again she's
if she's playing with do you know what
if she's playing with dolls when
automatically she's nine years old she
was playing with dolls still when it was
consummated so according to this she was
not mature yet right I don't I don't
think so no I don't think that's what
that's saying okay so what is it saying
then in that I'm saying in that passage
I don't think that it's saying after
they consummated the the marriage she
was still not not mature at the age of
puberty she was playing with dolls which
means she's immature right at the age of
puberty though we're talking internally
mature like mature according to the law
is playing with dolls forbidden unless
you're
immature according to the law is playing
with dolls forbidden unless you're
immature what you mean by that so
basically the only way that you can play
with dolls is if you're immature and a
little girl not reach puberty right
right I don't know I don't know all
right let's let's read this again the
playing with of the dolls and similar
images is
forbidden
forbidden but so here's the
caveat it was
allowed if if you feel like you're gonna
do that bro just go ahead and mute mute
before you burp my my fault come
on that's why I was AP
my bad man my fault but it was
allowed for Aisha at that time
why as she was a little girl not yet
reached the age of puberty so according
to the text the only reason why she's
able to play with dolls is because she
hasn't reached puberty and is a little
girl right got you so then go back to
the other one real quick you steps ahead
so when we go to the other
one when they consummated the marriage
at nine she still used to play with
dolls
right it said she used to I don't know
if she yeah C she's older now talking
about this she's not nine anymore she's
older now talking about this you're
right you're right so she's at nine got
the marriage consummated and still
played with dolls right okay I see I see
what you're saying I I I I see what
you're saying because the point about it
not being allowed unless they were at
that certain age you know that that adds
up I see what you're saying that's
that's another discussion I'll have to
have which is again why why uh so is
this okay now now that we know that
Aisha was actually a little girl still
playing with dolls and that was not
allowed because it showed a sign of her
immaturity is this okay bro uh I I can't
speak on it now you can speak on it
first at first I had a confident answer
as to why it was okay due to her
physical maturity but if it's um at this
point now I gotta have a discussion now
I gotta go do my research before I can
actually have an answer behind beliefs
I'm being honest with you I'm not
justifying nothing I'm not uh knocking
nothing I just got to go have a
discussion if Muhammad slept with Aisha
as an immature nine-year-old little girl
playing with dolls is that okay if she
wasn't mature enough for that
no all
right all right man so now I got a
question for you and this is a quick one
I ain't gonna lie because I was just
watching you and uan earlier um when you
brought up uh uh uh ahaziah or aah
whatever his name is his age in the in
the in the Bible and um him being 22 or
42 when he Reign reigned as king I just
want to know where you got the idea that
that he was kidnapped for 20 years and
then came back and reigned again well uh
I I Revisited that and saw that it was a
textural variant between 22 and 42 all
most of the manuscripts say 22 so we
know that he was 22 all so what you were
saying in the video where where did you
get that from um I got it from a reading
of the text by Mr red with further
research I found the it was just a
textual variant okay that's that's dope
I I just wanted to I wanted to ask you
that um I gave the verses in the in the
video of where um the sons were
kidnapped um after they were ransacked I
think it was by the Assyrians yeah it's
just that I had looked into it just a
little bit and it said that he got
killed that the people who kidnapped him
ended up killing him at at around
22 no yeah no that's that's not what
happened they kidnapped they kidnapped
but one of the sons was left at said one
of the sons was left and that was aiah
or whatever
yeah all right bro I'm way past my time
but I'm live every Monday Wednesday and
Friday all right I appreciate you for
having a convo with me I'm gonna try to
hop on a lot more especially once I get
my uh my knowledge up and I wanna I
wanna uh I but be real be real when you
when you address this stuff man I always
do did I come on here and be fake at all
don't make excuses for Muhammad did I
come on here and be fake be honest I I
think you made excuses for Muhammad I
did at first before we read what we read
and now I feel like there's I gotta go
Discover right I think I think that
making excuses for Muhammad it's not a
it's not a a good way to go about this
stuff you know so hey it's all good man
we all got to do our research bro if
things are right things are wrong I'm a
humble man you know I'm g go uh I'm
gonna go learn what I gotta learn that's
all all right here's here's a here's a
verse I want you to look into as well
look into in the Quran write this down
if you can look let me know
look into chapter 65
verse4 all right we'll do um oh well you
never really you never really um answer
the idea of why the the the how the
manuscripts have
um it's time to go bam you you you ain't
gonna answer that come back come back on
another live
all right man don't don't reject me man
I'm gon be back for real for real all
right peace appreciate
y'all all right guys with that being
said I think that's it